I'll start from the last diagram.
It shows the nav coming
in from the right,
see how it's over here off the canvas?
And then it comes in and
covers the canvas on the right side.
This one is wrong, because this
property translate negative 300 pixels,
means that the nav bar is starting 300
pixels to the left of the view port.
So, this can't be right.
In this example, it shows the nav
bar showing up from, well, nowhere.
It's not over here.
This is wrong.
According to the CSS over here,
it clearly exists somewhere.
In this example, the nav bar is starting
off to the left of the viewport, but
then when it comes in,
it pushes the content off the viewport.
This is wrong, because the position
of the nav element is absolute.
Which means that when it comes in it
will actually just cover
the existing content.
All that is to say that this diagram
accurately shows the way the navbar will
show up on screen.
And there you have it.
This is a good way to visualize the way
your navbar is sliding in on the screen.